[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster
I'm constant and kitten and this is to
show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
and fascinating people we have for you
today - brilliant returning guests to
trigonometry
here they are Jim records and people
Mangrum to expert economists people who
understand finance people who understand
what is going to happen tech as well as
with all of those things we're gonna get
into Jim people welcome back thank you
it's great it is great to have you back
so much to talk about
we were sounding very cheap I don't know
why we are in the middle of a global
pandemic Jim it no doubt is about to
tell us we're about to be in the global
depression so Jim is that right are we
about to descend into the biggest
financial collapse in the history of
amendment or you know living memory
let's say well maybe since the 14th
century but we're not I wouldn't say
we're about to be I would say we're in
it the data has not rolled in yet as you
know data comes for the lag we don't
even have first quarter GDP we'll have
that in about four more weeks or three
more weeks that will not reflect the
full impact of that I'd say we're really
it won't be till the end of July for
example that we get second quarter GDP
so that the data lags but there's enough
anecdotal data and I would say real pain
I mean we know 10 million people have
lost their jobs in about two weeks we
know that so you a lot of the best you
can do from inference so we're in I
think it's I don't pay homage enough to
economists to call it a recession
they'll call it a recession I call it a
depression oh really
and why do you why do you think we're
now in a depression is it because of the
lack of jobs that have been the look the
amount of jobs have been lost is it a
lack of economic activity or is it a
combination of the two well you know
I've said we've been in a depression
since 2007 at least as John Mayer Kings
to find it a lot of people don't
understand that they the the commercial
definition of a recession is two
consecutive quarters of declining grow
with a few other bells and whistles you
know rising unemployment the National
Bureau of Economic Research makes that
call and they say well gee if recession
is two quarters and a depression must be
ten quarters or something really
horrible and of course that hasn't
happened and probably won't happen this
time
but that's not the right definition of a
depression Keynes said that a depression
was a sustained period a below trend
growth with no tendency either to
complete collapse or return to normal in
other words it was depressed growth from
2009 to 2020 we had at least in the u.s.
2.2 percent annual growth and there
wasn't a lot of variation man that we
had no 3% years we had no negative years
the the degree distribution clustered
around 2.2 percent and there wasn't much
difference between Trump and Obama as
far as that's concerned but the long
longer term trend going back to 1980 was
3.2 percent if you go back to the end of
World War two it was even higher and as
we had growth but it was a significantly
lower than trend a full percentage point
people say oh gee 1 percent what's the
big deal sorry you take 1 percent times
a 20 trillion dollar economy and come
compounded over 11 years you get four
trillion dollars of lost wealth now
that's where we were going into the
epidemic going into the pandemic now
you're looking at declines of in the
second quarter you know no one knows but
20 to 30 percent not two or three
percent twenty to thirty percent
unprecedented even yeah first thing I
tell people is you know throw away 2008
throw away 1998 1994 tequila crisis
dot-com crash throw them all away
none of them are proper baselines for
understanding what we're seeing you have
to go back to 1929 but even then that
played out over four years between 1929
and 1933 this played out over about four
weeks so fair to say we've we've never
seen anything like it it's outside the
living experience of everyone on the
planet you'd have to be a hundred years
old I have a living memory of the
depression we'll deal with it but to
call this anything other than a
depression I think is
misleading all right well so essentially
what you're saying just to summarize for
people who maybe struggled to follow the
technical jargon essentially what you're
saying is we never really recovered from
the the crash in 2008 and we've been
growing you know people talk about the
squeeze on living standards earnings not
rising as fast as inflation and the cost
of whatever and we never fully recovered
and now we've come into a huge crisis
massively underprepared is that fair
assessment that's exactly right and and
you look at you know the Fed balance
sheet from 2008 to 2014
it went from 800 billion dollars to four
point five trillion dollars and quest
rates were zero through most of that
period what the Fed started what the Fed
tried to do beginning in 2014 they tried
to get interest rates back to three or
four percent they tried to get the
balance sheet down to about two point
five trillion or so and in their view
that would prepare them for the next
recession and because it usually takes
about four full percentage points of
rate cuts to get the US economy out of a
recession I set up at the time that they
would fail and just to be specific I
said the act of preparing for the next
recession would cause the recession they
were trying to prepare they would not be
able to do it without causing recession
they came really close to the end of
2018 between October 1st and December 24
2018 the stock market fell almost 20% so
we almost had our bear market then not
quite jpowel threw in the towel he said
we're not going to raise rates anymore
which they had been doing furthermore
we'll pause then he said in May we're
going to cut rates and he did then he
said we're gonna end quantitative
tightening that was the reduction of the
balance sheet normalization of the
balance sheet and he did and then
finally we REITs are back to zero so the
Fed to the Fed failed and their primary
mission to normalize the balance sheet
and interest rates they've now gone all
the way back to zero rates the Fed
balance sheet today is five trillion
dollars it's higher than it was at the
peak of QE three and so there you are
and the depression has just begun so
they're out of bullets they failed to
normalize we're
far less prepared than we were and and
now we're in the recession that everyone
feared except it's much worse than that
so so here we are economically
unprepared out of bullets no stimulus
from fiscal or monetary policy and we'll
see how things work out I'm really glad
I lived on a first owner ground floor
flat gym because I'd be tempted to lay
by the window otherwise her pepper would
you put a little bit of a sunnier spin
on it well I let me put it a different
way
just different way of understanding the
problem weirdly what's happening the
economy is a little bit like what
happens to the humans who are getting
kovin 19 and of course that's the the
the trigger that has knocked the economy
for six I so with with the disease one
of the things that kills you is not the
disease itself but the fact that your
body's immune system starts attacking
the disease and it ends up attacking
itself that's such a good analogy people
that is brilliant
mhm you see and now in capitalism what's
happening is businesses are going wow I
don't have enough cash flow to last
through this say whatever this lockdown
is gonna be three weeks three months so
I'll kill my business before it kills me
and they shut down and then this is why
you get the numbers Jim was quite
rightly talking about a sudden spurt and
unemployment that it's on such a scale
that it literally almost can't be
comprehended I and and Jim's right we
don't have any data and we're not going
to have any data in the same way we
don't have any data about koban 19 yet
we also don't have any data about the
economy so I would put it in this way
there is not going to be an average for
anyone about this economy so we can talk
about recession depression but everyone
will be touched by it very differently
and very personally so those who happen
to be in a part of the economy that's
now going to become massively more
efficient may end up in a better
situation than they were before and I
can give you some examples of that
those who are no longer needed because
for example big companies are going as
an example I talked to the CEO of a
major company the other day he says to
me and I quote him he says PIPA I just
realized that I the middle-aged white
guy was the biggest obstacle to going
digital in my company I didn't believe
you could work from home I didn't
believe you could be productive working
outside the office but now that I'm
forced to do it I am unbelievably
productive and I can see my whole team
is and then why do we have all these
overheads why do we have property why do
we own physical spaces anymore and so
that company I guarantee you is going to
emerge much leaner and meaner but
probably would less that so the people
that they are firing now who are showing
up in those unemployment numbers they're
gonna have to face the the world that
Jim is talking about which is a very
difficult situation because it's not
enough to have a skill set you have to
now shift into this new environment
where the skill sets are very different
than what was required before I go
further and say that I think policy
makers were on the backfoot
and slow to respond to Coba 19 and now
they're doing the same thing with the
economy because of their belief system
and their belief system is number one
that you can put the economy and snooze
mode it's just like an alarm you just
hit that little snooze mode button and
everything stops for whatever length the
time and then you can turn it back on
again but this is not how the economy
works because of cash flow and people
who don't have enough cash to make it
this is where the societal problem is
and I'm not just talking about
businesses that don't have enough cash
flow I'm talking about a world in which
something like as much as 60% of people
in industrialized countries like the
United States and Britain spends on next
month's paycheck and maybe 30% of them
depend on next week's paycheck and I
think the stats in the u.s. were
something like actually I won't quote
the exact number because I don't
remember but it's a huge number of
people who only have about four hundred
dollars in savings it's about 50% paper
by half the country it's a big number so
now we have to think about the human
consequences of this very sudden this
very abrupt halt in economic activity
now the second mistake policymakers are
making is the assumption they'd be just
Chuck a ton of money at this thing
that'll do it and that is why they
announced this unlimited quantitative
easing and the problem there is that
well you can announce it but the
mechanism for getting the money into
people's bank accounts whether it's a
corporate or a personal was essentially
through the tax office like Britain the
HMRC or it was through bank loans well
the banks are saying I'm not lending to
anybody in the current situation because
everybody's credit quality is collapsed
and so the bank mechanism doesn't work
and the government mechanism just takes
too long so time is the one factor that
in markets would tend to take for
granted and this is the one thing that
we now have no control over and can't
quantify into any of our models because
the answer to the question how bad is
the economy going to be is very
different for two days from now two
weeks from now and two months from now
and I think that's what policymakers
haven't clocked and throwing money at it
and putting it on snooze mode doesn't
fix any of these things so in conclusion
what I'd say is that one can fall into a
sense of being so awestruck by the
severity of what's happened that they
can't think straight you were just in a
place of total fear how are you gonna
survive and we can call that lots of
different names depression recession
that's enter or we can say okay what
government has done at least in the UK
they've said no mortgage payments no
rent payments no tax payments for three
months so at least in the UK everybody's
got a little time in the US the
government has not chosen to buy time in
the same way and I really mean by time
and this is maybe the thing that
think about Soper for those who now have
a bit of time to think about this this
is a little bit of a gift as well
because we don't often get time to think
about how we're going to manage our
future and I see ways in which we can
begin to identify where the new
opportunities gonna be so just like in
the 1920s and 30s
what you did in the 20s is not what you
did in the 30s and just like after the
Spanish flu I'll point out you know
what's the big question to my mind is
not in just the economic question it's
the human psychology question and I'll
finish with this you know in in the year
and after the the Spanish flu but also
surviving World War one what did people
do with all that damage to the world
economy I mean worse than arguably what
we're facing now because many many more
people died many more businesses were
shut down they basically said you know
what I want to live and those who could
afford it became the great Gatsby's and
spent it on champagne and the 20s are
famous for being as an era of excess and
I could see that the era that follows
this moment in time could be like that
but at the same time 60% of Americans
were on or below the poverty line in the
1920s and I could also see that - in
other words a bifurcation of the society
and then my thing I would put in front
of people it's a bigger question is ok
how do you make sure that that doesn't
last too long and the big view in the
policy world is that Ben Bernanke is
right he studied the Great Depression
and the answer is the central bank just
keeps expanding their balance sheet and
you just nationalize everything and
basically you end up in socialism and I
think Amity slays is right and she wrote
a book saying no actually the the
politicians prolonged the slowdown by
becoming so interventionist and it would
have passed more quickly if they'd let
the market sort itself out and clear all
these broken assets and that's the
question today is yes the assets are
broken they're gonna be broken it's
gonna get messy but how
quickly can we clear it is the answer to
the question how bad is it going to be
well this is really the question that I
want to talk in it's a very simple
question for you guys who are experts in
this but a lot of ordinary people would
be saying well you know when we had our
election in this country in the UK at
the end of 2019 the big argument was is
there a magic money tree or is there not
a magic money tree can you give people
free stuff or not and it seems like the
people who said that you can't are now
giving people free stuff and the real
question is the people don't think no
the answer to and this is for both of
you is where is that money coming from
and what is gonna be the cost of that
money down the line so I think this is
the the key question because you know
and I've been on your show before
talking about my concern that inflation
was already higher than our policymakers
were willing to say and they were like
the place is not a problem it's gone
away you know we don't even have to read
about that in a textbook anymore it's
such an old issue and anybody who raised
it like me is like you completely lost
your marbles and I'm like wait a minute
but you know you buy a box of cereal in
the market and it's cost the same but
the amount of cereal inside keys being
less and you know your rent is going up
and the cost of of whiskey and a bar is
going up and so the data may not say
that there's been such a big jump though
the data has said there has been a jump
but not a huge one so therefore it's a
non-issue well and then they blasted
free money through the market with the
financial crisis and quote nothing bad
happens and I'm like okay but that
doesn't mean that all the rules have
gone away and if you flood the market
now with free money the risk is you no
longer have the downward pressure on
prices that was being caused by the
Chinese providing ever cheaper products
at ever better quality that is no longer
happening because the supply chain they
call it the supply chain is broken at
both ends what that means is the the
willingness from China to sell abroad is
diminished and the demand for their
goods is diminished both so we no longer
have that in fact we're seeing the
restoring on
shirring of production which as an aside
I think might be a good thing for the
world economy but it means higher prices
for a period of time and second tech and
I'm in the tech world
you know I'm manufacturing drones and
autonomous vehicles and and data systems
for digitizing and the reality is that
the tech world is being hit by this
quite hard so you're not going to have
endless innovation always pushing prices
down so before we had free money pushing
prices up but China and tech holding it
down now we don't have that and we have
more free money against the backdrop and
I come back to human psychology against
the backdrop of this lockdown where
people are willing to pay a dollar or a
pound for a single egg right like you've
experienced now a run on the grocery
store so you're like you know it
actually five pounds or five dollars for
a loaf of bread maybe that's okay and
this is the genie that's out of the
bottle it's not inflation it's inflation
expectations and where we should look
for that is in humans and in their
belief system rather than in the bond
market usually that's the thing you look
at to tell you what the expectations are
the bottom R is no longer signaling
clearly because everybody has to buy
bonds because the stock market Falls so
it doesn't give you a clear
understanding but if people start to say
well you know I'm gonna save a little
bit more because I need more security in
the future and I want to be sure I could
afford those eggs if we get a second
lockdown this is how inflation
expectations begin so I am concerned
that one issue is the inflation is going
to be unleashed a little bit by these
policy actions at a time when
policymakers are like don't be
ridiculous that's a complete non-issue
you've lost your marbles so the same
question for you sorry just like what do
I want to get yes is there gonna be hell
to pay for for the money that we are now
using to save people's jobs and protect
businesses no there's there's no chance
of inflation in fact the the real
concern is and will be deflation now
down the road I'm when I say down the
road I mean a year-to-year
from now there is a risk of very serious
inflation bordering on hyperinflation
but not now and not for at least a year
and here's why inflation has nothing to
do with money supply this is sort of a
I've called a myth or a misunderstanding
that's been propagated by everyone from
the neo-keynesian to the monetarist to
the Austrians you know an increase in my
supply too much money chasing too few
goods inflation is right around the
corner it's not true money supply has
nothing to do with inflation
what does drive inflation is psychology
it which shows up in the form of
velocity so let's say I have a say I'm
feeling good I go out to dinner you know
I tipped the waiter he takes a taxi home
and tips the taxi driver and the taxi
driver takes the tip and puts gas in her
taxi
well that in that example my dollar has
velocity of 3 there was a tip a taxi tip
and guess lean so velocity of 3 instead
imagine I stay home and watch television
my money has velocity of 0 right never
mind well that five trillion dollars
times zero is zero if you don't have
velocity you don't have an economy
period so the task is and a pivot
touched on this she's exactly right
the task is to change the psychology
change expectations
you can print all the money you want the
fake can stick the landing on base money
m0 mmm you know 1 m2 is a different
matter but m0 they can print that to a
two decimal places
not a problem but they can't get people
to lend it they can't get people to
spend it they can't get people to to
just save in other words what are people
doing with the money they are they are
either going to well if you have a high
marginal propensity to consume meaning
you're you know you're living paycheck
to paycheck and you need to pay the rent
yes you'll pay the rat fair enough
but for many people they will save it
for the reason Pippa mentioned which is
they're worried about how long it's
gonna last you know even if you're not
laid off if your neighbor was laid off
you're probably worried about your own
job so you'll save it on a precautionary
basis or you'll pay off you know credit
card pay down the road alone which is
economically
same thing it's just another form of
saving so that's what people gonna do
with the money there you won't see the
velocity from it
monetary policy is completely impotent
it doesn't mean that there can't be bad
consequences from what's happening and
I'll touch on that but you know I say
well you know the feds printing you know
five trillion dollars by the way the
feds taking this balance sheet to ten
trillion dollars let's be clear about
that it's five trillion dollars today
now about a week ago a little more the
our Congress passed this two point two
trillion dollar economic rescue bill
whatever you want to call it the cares
Act was that it was the technical name
they're probably gonna throw another
trillion on top of that and in a couple
of weeks buried inside the two point two
trillion was four hundred and fifty
billion approximately to recapitalize
the Fed and I've said for a long time
you know because look what the Fed did
in the last couple of weeks and actually
can go back to 2008 and say the same
thing they guaranteed every money market
fund they guaranteed every piece of
commercial paper they guaranteed the
primary dealers they're buying corporate
bonds to buy municipal bonds they've
guaranteed everything and then I would
ask the question who guarantees the Fed
well we now have an answer which is the
Treasury so the Treasury took this four
hundred and fifty billion dollars and
they're investing it in the Fed
recapitalizing the Fed I had dinner with
one of the Fed governors it was small
group and I looked at her and said you
know at the time interest rates were
higher than they are now and the Fed was
technically insolvent on the
mark-to-market basis now they don't
mark-to-market I understand that but if
you were a hedge fund which they kind of
look like you would mark to market and
they were insolvent so I said you know
your banks insolvent and she said no
we're not and I said I think you are and
she said no in some work I said I've
done it and I think others had done it
and then she looked at me around a
little bit and said central banks don't
need capital though that's an exact
quote and I said well you might the
American people might disagree well it
turns out that Merck do disagree and
they did put four hundred and fifty
billion dollars of capital from the
Treasury into the Fed but here's the
point the Fed is some kind of bank and
they're going to leverage it ten to one
they're gonna take that 450
billion and turn it into four point five
trillion dollars a balance sheet on top
of the five trillion they have as we
speak that's nine and a half trillion
make it ten for round number they're
taking the balance sheet to ten trillion
dollars now that's not stimulus it's
money printing it's down sheet expansion
the Fed is keeping the lights on they've
provided liquidity where it's needed
they've made sure the plumbing of the
financial system did not get clogged so
I'll give them credit for throwing
liquidity where you need liquidity and I
guess as I say keeping the lights on but
that's all it is that's all it is this
is not stimulus and the same thing is
true with a monetary fiscal policy so
the u.s. had approximately one trillion
dollar deficit for fiscal 2020 going
into this so one trillion dollars
deficit was your baseline they threw 2.2
trillion on top of that they're certain
to throw another trillion or more so
we're looking at a five trillion dollar
deficit perhaps more for fiscal 2020
which is 25 percent of GDP so we've got
a 25 percent of GDP deficit we've got a
fed balance sheet that will be 50
percent of GDP but I just tell people
over and over I said don't call a
stimulus you can call it spending it's
spending for sure but don't call it
stimulus why is that well here you have
to look to the research of Carmen
Reinhart and Ken Rogoff the Karma was at
University of Maryland for a long time
they're both G's of the Kennedy School
Rogoff is at Harvard Economics
Department
they've done books studies by themselves
with each other with other collaborators
a whole series of papers they're all
available they're all publicly available
and they've looked at they've looked
over centuries they've looked at just
the 20th century developing economies
only developed economies only various
subsets they got the same result every
single time that when your debt to
equity czar your debt to GDP ratio goes
over 90 percent you've crossed what
businesses call a critical threshold
you're in you're through the
looking-glass and whatever Keynesian
multiplier might have exist you know
Keynes called his theory the general
theory of employment interest and
and money is a little bit of Einstein
I'd be going on there with the general
theory it's actually but they call
special theory special theory means it
applies in limited circumstances and
Keynes was right if you're coming out of
a recession if you have spare capacity
if your debt is not too high and if
you're in a liquidity trap then yes
government spending in lieu of private
spending can have a multiplier it's kind
of going back to my taxicab example with
with high velocity if you get it
and so you borrow a dollar spend a
dollar and you get a dollar 20 of GDP
that works you know maybe temporary but
but it works but now once you go past
ninety percent you borrow a dollar spend
a dollar and you get ninety cents of GDP
in other words you don't even get a
dollar so so what does that do to the
ratio well you're increasing the debt
increase in the numerator faster than
you're increasing the denominator the
denominator up very slowly the numerator
is skyrocketing and your debt to GDP
ratio is getting worse so the US is
gonna catch up to to Italy before long
we because here's what we were 106
percent going into this and then if
ninety percent is critical threshold in
the data says it is
we were 106 percent going in we're gonna
take it to 116 percent you know Italy's
about 120 to Lebanon and I think leads
the pack but they're they're shutting
down so you're not gonna get the
stimulus unless you will get spending
you will get higher deficits so if
monetary policy can't stimulate because
of low velocity which is a psychological
phenomena and a fiscal policy can't
stimulate because we're past the
critical threshold and the expectation
is that hey you can borrow all you want
by way to pay it back in taxes or better
save more you get zero stimulus that's
what you've got one more point I'll
finish quickly Pippa talked about the
you know the 50 year old white guy
whatever who was maybe a little bit in
tech and decide to wake up college about
that and and it does but think of the
and I think she's exactly right about
that think of the consequences of that
so I'm a salmon restaurant owner in a
medium-sized city and I've got 50
employees and I've closed my doors and
all my employees have laid off they are
laid off there but they all apply front
man and I've applied for one of these
small business loans which which you
would qualify for okay now let's just
say flash-forward to July hopefully you
know the diseases contained I don't know
that's not a forecast but that'll be
true or not but it could be true so
let's say by July August things are
getting back to normal the restaurants
open customers are returning am I going
to hire back all of my employees and I
did where those 20 or 50 however many am
I gonna hire them all back now odds are
I had a couple underperformers odds are
my way some clients they return but not
all of them I've got a reduced my tables
because I've got a socially just since
my tables maybe I hired back half maybe
I hired back two thirds but what about
the rest they're not getting hired back
so this this is why I made the point
earlier about a depression course
unemployment is gonna spike we know that
the question is how quickly will return
to normal I go back to the answer is it
won't I go back to 2009 we all remember
it very well
and what were the talking heads on CNBC
talking about green shoots remember
green shoots you know Tim Geithner and
Joe Karen and Larry Kudlow we're all
talking about green shoots there were no
green shoots we got brown weeds we did
not get a be sure to come we've got kind
of an l-shaped recovery with a slightly
upward sloping recovery curve that that
was sloping at a narrower range than the
pre the pre global financial crisis
curve in other words that's the 2.2
percent I talked about what if it comes
back now and that's 1.7 percent let me
see the point it's not that we're not
going to grow yeah we'll grow off a
demolish base at a lower rate and we
will not solve the problem of persistent
unemployment and just one more thing
quickly I you know I I'm a I'm a sole
proprietor I'm a writer analyst public
speaker etc so I qualify for these small
business loans so I put in for one you
know I'm not you know you don't need to
shed any tears but I want to see how it
would go and it was interesting the
banks for days did not post the form
Citibank this is disgrace still has not
posted their form they recommend you
apply of the bank where you do your
banking because they know you so I
applied to my back they were a little
bit late
and I got the form that's kind of check
the box to everything but my business
does not conform to their form they
wanted w-2s they wanted there's
something we call form 941 I said
quarterly or monthly statement to the
IRS here are my employees you know they
went on my payroll I don't have a paper
I hire editors I hire research
assistants I paid them I send them 1099s
so all said I'm trying to like you know
upload a 1099 into a form that once at
9:41 you know my point is it they and
I'm not I'm not
you know folding the bank's this all
happened how do you get how do you get a
three hundred eighty five billion
dollars out the door in five days that
was sort of the question
you know the Small Business
Administration computers have crashed
the forms that the bank's put online
don't conform to the reality of what
else imagine you're an LLC or a sole
proprietor which I am or whatever I just
said I want to see if this worked and
the answer is it didn't work very well
so I don't I don't care what Larry
Kudlow says on TV nice guy by the way
but the worst forecasting record except
for the feds they cannot get the money
out the door so the rescue package is
not getting out the door when it does
you know when I was nine years old as
the Boy Scout learned how to apply a
tourniquet well a tourniquet stops the
bleeding perhaps at the cost of a limb
you might save a life but don't think
you put the tourniquet on and the
patient's up and doing a triathlon
anytime soon that's a life-saving
exercise and all of these programs we've
heard about are first of all there are
isin is about two and a half months
there's no stimulative effect whatsoever
I'm not saying they're not needed I'm
not saying they're not needed they are
needed but the idea that this is gonna
save the day is nonsense Jim you know
when you said about 385 billion how to
get it out the door I think you guys for
the moment you need a Venezuelan
politician they'd make it disappear
instantly just like that I'm sure they
were volunteers they've run the program
for us yeah absolutely
and Jim and do you see it as and this
question to pepper as well were we had a
guest last week who said that in times
of crisis usually war that is the moment
that the government introduced new taxes
or in particular higher taxes do you
think when we come out of this yet we're
going to get taxed
to the eyeballs or the government gonna
hold back because they're gonna realize
we've been through major financial
trauma and we just need to invigorate
the economy and we need to grow
confidence well there's I don't think
they'll raise taxes and in the second
chopped administration they're really
not inclined to do that although you
know just jump your head a little bit I
know you like to look down the road a
little bit the market is struggling too
I mean what markets do they price news
right and the bigger the news is the
bigger the repricing we've seen that so
the markets try to stock market that is
trying to price in the pandemic and
they're struggling because no one really
knows but you know okay they're doing a
pretty good job with that then they're
trying to price in you know call the
recession depression v-shaped l-shape
there's a lot of debate about that but
they're trying to price that and that's
more difficult because the economy's
bigger and it's more complex and you
know I had my forecasts but others have
theirs the one thing they have not
priced in is President Biden I have a
you know I do the political of forecast
predictive analytics in addition to
economics and you know I was on TV
around the world in late October 2016
promoting my book and all the anchors
from Australia London and New York said
hey Jim you're the America who's going
to win the election I said Trump's gonna
win it will be up late it'll be close
but he's gonna win after they recovered
their breath and you know sort of you
know got their a demeanor back together
the sy and I explained why this is it
when Hillary had a 92% probability of
winning according to awesome pundits I
have the same model I've updated of
course I had Trump about 75% probability
of winning and increasing monthly
because it was theta in terms of the
recession well Jim if you remember sorry
to interrupt last time you were on the
show what you said specifically was if
the economy continues to do well he's
gonna get reelected the time the three
of us won't worry of course is gonna
continue to do well I mean how but here
we are yeah it was easier the second
time but but the point is the fact that
we're in you know I'll call it a
depression it doesn't mean that Trump's
going to lose if we were not he would
almost certainly win but just because we
are it doesn't mean he's going to lose
and the reason is that no one blames him
for the virus he will be judged on his
handling of this and that's that's a
separate issue he won't be judged for
causing it he'll the Chinese will but
he'll he'll be judged for handling it so
right now I've got about 5050 and I use
Bayesian base theorem and as part of the
deployed mathematics we use so 5050
people say let's wish you or she know
that that's where you start and a
Bayesian equation if you don't have
better information you start a 50/50
bill then you update on posterior
information so we'll see how it plays
out but that means you got to give Joe
Biden a 50% chance also so it's a coin
toss but the market hasn't priced that
end I mean what does the Biden
presidency mean higher taxes more
regulation you know kissing up to China
and the green New Deal how you think
stock markets gonna like that so this
has a long way to go people on what
about you what are your thoughts about
you know Francis point about and
actually it feeds very much into your
point which is if you see taxes coming
down the line you're gonna your
psychology is well save save save
because I'm not gonna have enough money
in the future I need to be careful and
then that creates a vicious cycle what
do you see I mean I personally haven't
seen some of job you know I mean we had
the Scott Adams on the show a couple of
weeks ago talking about among other
things Joe Biden yeah I mean he I don't
mean to be unkind but he's clearly in a
cognitive decline so I don't I don't see
him being the next president I mean Jim
will have his mathematical models which
are much more accurate than my
instinctive feeling but I just don't see
that but take that out of it what do you
see coming down the line in terms of
people's psychology as you say and also
the government's response you know are
we gonna see more taxes and how
how is everything gonna look - two or
three years from now I take your point
about you know winners and losers but
there will be a bigger picture to the
turn than that as well yeah well you
know my last book was about leadership
and I sort of argued between the lines
we have a lot of leaders who are in
cognitive nobody's got a monopoly on
that right now
I let me come on this question of taxes
all the conversations were having is
very much within the framework were used
to conversing in and what I see is this
is such a structural change we're gonna
have a very different conversation
because it's not going to be about tax
it's going to be about nationalization
and read privatization for example as
you opened you said you know the Labour
Party in Britain was saying we'll give
away free stuff then the Conservatives
came in and that's exactly what they did
and so Labour's like wait a minute that
was our program well then what is what
are the Conservatives today they're like
well okay we we have to keep the trains
running and if Network Rail can't afford
to do this well we can nationalize
Network Rail well good luck with running
Network Rail because it's a complex
difficult beast to run and I'm betting
they won't take them very long to figure
out they have to privatize it so what
you're talking about is not taxes but a
world where expropriation of assets
where government just takes stuff and
tries to manage it can't and tries to
sell it to someone for cash this stuff
happens much more frequently and less
this less with less of a kind of overall
plan than we're used to so it's very
bumpy I and also things like property
you know there's reasons the Italians
always call it a Moby Lea it's because
it's in mobile it's can't be moved and
this makes it easier for government to
seize or tax or or already look at we're
seeing because of the crisis the health
care crisis you know physical
establishments get repurposed whether
that's the Excel stadium becomes a
hospital a church in New York
Cathedral in New York becomes a hospital
and and rightly so I'm just saying this
is how it begins the government's say
forget about tax I'm just taking the
thing we need it right now and this
mentality is exactly what happened and
again in the 1930s so I don't think it's
so much the traditional sense of tax
it's the the real question is what do I
actually own and what private
protections of private property really
exist and this going to test the
Constitution of the United States going
to test the unwritten Constitution of
the United Kingdom and so I think that's
one big issue the second thing I that's
relevant here is also it's the relative
story and so what I see is if I'm going
to go back to the Cova nineteen medical
analogy again what kills the patients is
pre-existing conditions I mean some of
them are dying just straight out from
the disease but a lot of people what
gets them is they already were in bad
shape and that's exactly what happened
with the economy the economy was way
overburdened with leverage and debt the
economy had valuations that did were off
the chart and didn't make any sense in
terms of real cash flow and reality so
now the patient comes in and technically
what's making them ill is the cove in
nineteen but the doctor takes one look
and says this is a heart attack waiting
to happen this is a this is a cancer
patient in stage four that's been
revealed by the crisis so in the world
of economics what is causing that cancer
and the answer is the debt so what I
expect is a lot of debt is gonna get
defaulted on now this is a very scary
thing to talk about everybody goes oh no
this is the end of the world economy but
maybe we can turn this around and we can
look at this as a very positive thing
you guys know from in the past I've
talked about the different ways that
governments can default on their debt
right option one is you say I am never
paying you guys back and you're just
tough that's called the Argentine style
default and then the markets hate you
the credit markets put you in the junk
bin
and you stay there for a decade or more
but a second way is you say oh listen I
am absolutely definitely gonna pay you
back and I'm so sorry that this act of
God got in the way and it's just I'm
gonna pay you a little bit less and a
little bit later and everyone goes well
that doesn't sound so bad and that's how
Greece defaulted on a huge proportion of
their debt now mathematically it's a
default but because you don't call it
default you say it's just a delay we're
just buying time we have every intention
of paying you back suddenly actually the
media the FT will write about that
they'll never describe that as a default
now the countries that have defaulted
Iceland Greece Portugal their economies
are actually going vastly vastly better
than they were before and now countries
like Italy confronted by this terrible
weight this cancer of overwhelming debt
now they have a crisis that reveals just
how bad it is what are the chances that
they say we can we can there are a lot
of pain for decades to come
paying this back or we can say there's
been an act of God it was completely out
of control and we're really sorry but
we're definitely gonna pay back it's
just a little bit later well then you
relieve them from some of that debt
burden now in a world where that's
happening and let's add emerging markets
because all the emerging markets
borrowed in dollars and now their
currencies are weakening and the dollar
strengthening so the level of debt is
going through the roof and already the
IMF is saying we may have to create some
kind of a bailout program using you know
mechanisms we've had in the past they
call sdrs but basically it means we're
gonna have to throw money at them
because they're not gonna be able to
make their loan payments what are the
chances that one of them says well let's
just not pay it back let's do it nicely
and say well we'll do the Intendant but
you know it's health crisis now in that
world you go to the country who you
think isn't gonna do this and so even if
the United States has this terrible
balance sheet so it's a patient the
blood pressure is off the chart they're
overweight they've also got cancer but
you go
relatively you know I trust the US when
the chips are down when everything is
hitting the wall globally what do you
define as safe and the answer is usually
the US no we can argue about whether
that happens this time or not I think
Britain can also emerge as that safe
landing place but a whole lot of other
places I think are going to start
defaulting now the initial reaction is
everybody scared a lot of losses
secondary reaction is hey we excise the
cancer the the debt is gone that means
actually we can grow again and so I just
wonder whether what's gonna happen is we
end up getting rid of a lot of the debt
burden on the world's economy and
instead of having to blame the bankers
or blame the policymakers or you usually
have to blame somebody this time we're
gonna blame a bug and so that can be ya
the perfect scapegoat and let's take
let's look at things globally a lot more
under this is a question to both of you
you know there's been this trend that
we've seen globalization as a universal
positive you know it's it's a great
thing we're more interconnected than
ever where this virus is pandemic that
has swept the globe aided and abetted by
you know the fact that we travel
everywhere are we now going to look at
globalization as being something that we
embrace without considering many of the
disadvantages and flaws behind it
globalization is dead I mean it should
have died a long time ago but it you
know it's kind of struggle on but we
will you know that this period of
globalization we lived through between
nineteen I would I make it 1989 to 2010
or thereabouts it was the second age of
globalization the first age of
globalization was 1870s in 1914 and yeah
there was free trade and bankers in
London were selling bonds to investors
in New York on Argentine credit and you
know letters of credit we're moving
there's trade moving all over the world
and you know that it kind of resembled
the late 20th century and then it hit a
brick wall at seven
in our cold world war one and the New
York Stock Exchange was closed for five
months between August and December 1914
and as were most major stock exchanges
around the world and the gold standard
ended immediately people went through
the pretense of having go what they did
they hoarded the physical gold and just
printed money so said that ended and
then you know you know the rest
hyperinflation in the early twenties
Depression 1930s World War two cold war
you know and it was until fall of
communism and in stages between 1989 and
1991 that we got back to globalization
but it was it the second time the first
time was real the second time was a
fraud you had people like you know
Jeffrey Sachs at Columbia and Richard
Haass at the Council on Foreign
Relations and a lot of others promoting
this but what it really was was was an
enormous theft from the United States of
financial capital intellectual capital
intellectual property etc for the
benefit of China and I'd like to say
that you know the aankhen were sent up
or communist is a rich communist so what
we did is we created a lot of rich
communists and here we are but no the
globalization is dead it has been
completely discredited Tom Friedman and
Richard Hans and their n Sachs and the
rest can go off and write their papers
but the real world has has moved on I
want to just come back for one second on
Pippa's description of how you default
and she was exactly right I actually
wrote negotiated and wrote along with
the few others the first sovereign
credit default swap we did this in the
early 90s when was it long-term capital
management we we bought a 1 billion
dollar insurance policy on Italian to
fall from Sumitomo Bank Milan because
they had the assets they didn't mind the
liabilities but this was long before
esta an automation a misto is rampant
they didn't have standard credit default
swap forms so I had to do it on a blank
sheet of paper and my colleague did the
math but my job was to figure out how
many ways can a government screw you
over like how many ways can you default
and pip is right yeah first one is just
I don't pay you that's easy then but we
had we had many
like 20 different ways because I knew if
I left one out it never happened I'd be
in trouble so but you know they can say
well pay you but I've grossly devalued
my currency so good luck buying a loaf
of bread another one is I'll pay you but
I've put on a hundred percent capital
control so as they said a gilja I had
coming come and take it
you know said there many many ways to do
it but a pip is right but and by the way
what she was describing goes back to
antiquity and there was explicit
biblical references but even earlier and
in Babylonian kingdoms it's called a
jubilee and the idea in listen in the
Bible in the Book of Leviticus every 50
years all the deaths would be forgiven
because they knew that people over
borrow they knew that people lend it
recklessly they knew that the system was
over burdened by debt this is all very
clear and they say where every 50 years
were wiping out the debt and so you say
well wait a second isn't that a little
unfair of the the the creditor is the
lenders you know but but the point is
the lenders weren't dopes so in the
first after the Jubilee in the first
year of a new expansion I would be very
comfortable making a five-year loan you
know secured by lamb but when you get to
year 40 in a 50 year cycle knowing
what's coming you're not gonna make a 10
year loan and you're 40 you'll probably
make a one-year loan and buy your forty
five you know you're not making any loss
and hit but here's the point it's and
this really gets into the physics of it
the system with foresight knowing the
rules voluntarily deed leveraged itself
in stages so that the Jubilee was not a
train wreck it was like there wasn't
that much sediment because people
started coming and so what what you were
really doing was was setting the
thermostat in such a way that it would
be self-regulating right I'm sure some
toys what we've done is the opposite
we've taken the brakes off the train
that's because we go that's because we
got rid of the Jubilee concept now we
have something better than a Jubilee
that that Pippo did not mention and it
is look everyone else can default on
their debt including their dollar John
Adair and emerging markets Aaron you
have Argentinian train wrecks all over
the place and she's right about that but
it all comes back to the United States
how does the
default there is no reason for us to
default because we can print the money
the way the US defaults is inflation and
in other words even modest and player 3%
inflation for 18 years
cuts the value of the dollar in half
which means the real value of the debt
goes down by heaven by the way we did
this in 1945 the US debt to GDP ratio
was 120 percent the highest in history
and I like to say yeah but at least we
won the war you know along with our
allies so we got something for it we
were the the the we had 50% of the world
economy but between between 1945 and
1980 the debt to GDP ratio declined from
a hundred and twenty percent to 30
percent when Ronald Reagan was sworn in
the debt to GDP ratio was thirty percent
and he was he was the first of the big
spenders and it's been going up ever
since today we're back to the World War
two levels but how did we do that we did
it with a couple of things finish what's
called financial financial dollar fiscal
dominance our financial dominance which
has been explained by Rick Michigan
where basically the Fed is the
handmaiden of the Treasury and they keep
rates low and all you need is negative
real rates basically if inflation is
just slightly higher than than the
nominal rate so we nominal rates of two
three percent in most of the 50s in the
early 60s but inflation was just a
little higher than that which meant that
it was like an ice cube melting in your
hands it didn't it wasn't abrupt
it wasn't like blatant theft like FDR
did when he confiscated the gold in 1933
although he gave you twenty dollars in
paper money's to not violate the Fifth
Amendment but the point is that's how
you do it now here's here's the dilemma
the Fed has been trying to engineer this
for twelve years and they failed I like
to say it's a sad day when a central
bank once inflation and can't get it
including all the employees at my
hypothetical restaurant does not hire
back and all the I forget which
presidential candidate said well who
cares what manufacturers get laid off we
can teach them to code
good luck there's no evidence that
people in midlife mid-career with one
skill set which could be valuable can
somehow retool themselves and become
coders and that's probably a good thing
but they can't do it there's no evidence
for that so how do you get out of this
embedded high unemployment embedded
deflationary psychology classic
liquidity trap you know name you're you
know put out your descriptor they they
all apply how do you get out of that the
answer is inflation but how do you get
in place when the inflationary
psychology is so bad it has been done
twice and I could do it in 15 minutes
and explain this in a couple of my books
you call an emergency meeting of the
Federal Reserve Board you go in the room
you close the door you take a vote you
come out you walk up to the microphone
you say ladies and gentlemen as of today
the price of gold is $5,000 per ounce if
you think that's cheap come and get it
we got a lot in Fort Knox if you think
that's expensive serve it up we'll pay
you for it and we got the printing press
and I was if you use the gold in Fort
Knox and West Point that's where the
most of the gold is if you use the gold
the physical gold and storage and the
printing press to conduct basically an
open market operation and gold this is
exactly this is how we paying interest
rates we we buy securities with printing
money and we sell them back and make the
money disappear
if you use the printing press in the
physical gold to maintain a fuss a 5,000
dollar per ounce price of gold it's not
to enrich gold investors it's to get the
price of everything else everything else
separate FDR did this when he took you
know in the greatest period of sustained
inflation in US history from 1927 in
1933 the price of gold went up 75% from
roughly $20 to $35 an ounce why was that
well FDR did the government made it
happen on a kind of gold standard at the
time but what he was really doing this
is what people don't understand when the
price of gold goes up 75% nothing really
happened the gold that's you know it
stomach number 79 it's it's a metal what
happened was the dollar was devalued by
80 percent and the price of everything
else went up
FDR one of the price of oil corn we
copper everything to go and it did 1933
was one of the greatest years in the
history of the stock market because he
bent the curve on deflation Richard
Nixon did the same thing by accident
Richard Nixon wasn't trying to do it the
way FDR did but he did it anyway
by suspending the reduction of dollars
into gold 97
what happened by 1980 I mean I took out
my first mortgage loan in 1980 it was
13% my poor mother cried you know my her
first mortgage was like 2% um but I said
mom inflation is 15% so my pre tax rate
is negative - that's that's cheap money
that's that's better than free money and
we have 50% taxes in New York at the
time so my after-tax real rate was
negative 7 so they were there apparently
a lot too to be a borrower so I see what
you're saying Jim so basically the
government is gonna the only option in
terms of what you're saying is the
government is gonna have to somehow
induce inflation and you would not be
Jim Rickards if the answer didn't have
something to do with gold it's not me
but here's the problem we have we have
two generations of monetary scholars who
were completely ignorant of gold they
like to say if you're younger than I am
and you know anything about gold you
either went to mine in college or you're
self-taught because the University
stopped teaching it it's a disreputable
subject we have all these that's why I
wrote my book the new case for gold to
explode all these myths but they persist
because you know the PhD he's not
reading my books but everyday Americans
do so that so it will come to that the
reason I'm saying that is because it's
the only thing that works FDR and
Richard Nixon both proved it burn burn I
see I see Jim let me stop you there
because I do want to move on to
globalization and PIPA and if I just
need to stop you there as well I saw a
quibble there Jim you'll find that we
won the war you assisted it but apart
from
actually can I just say at this point
that we won the war you guys tried to
take the credit nice job nice job at to
work you do
we were fighting on the Eastern Front
but anyway talk to us about
globalization because I mean I think one
of the absolutely I couldn't agree more
with Jim I think you know globalization
as constructed up to this point is dead
but as you said in terms of individuals
there'll be winners and losers I think
also in terms of nations and in terms of
kind of how we relate to each other
there will be that as well so what do
you see on that front going forward so
the definition of words is very
malleable over time I think what we're
going to find is the old definition of
globalization was all the stuff gets
made in China and all the jobs get moved
to China the new definition of
globalization is that stuff will be made
everywhere in the world and that people
will relocate to buy from more
physically local suppliers and that
means we're going to end up with a lot
more competition globally so actually
this isn't a lot it isn't that the end
of globalization it's a transformation
into an entirely new definition of what
constitutes globalization it's a world
where I think people like like me I
don't know if you guys know Etsy which
is an online craft shop in the United
States it's been huge and I think
there's going to be a need now for a
global Etsy because you want to buy some
beautiful necklace made by a Maasai
warrior in Kenya and you don't want to
have to fly all the way there to get it
and you want to support those local
communities by buying the products that
they make and actually now the new
internet world will facilitate this so
weirdly our we may become more global in
our spending pattern
on a optional basis but in terms of you
know grocery stores you're gonna say you
know what I'd rather rely on local
British food for example there's a
fishmonger and Notting Hill and their
sales have gone up like 2,000 percent
since this crisis began because
everybody wants to work with the local
fish shop that gets their fishermen
locally and so that's a localization
that supports the local economy but that
doesn't mean that there won't be a
market for some of their fish products
ending up in France or North America you
know we live in a world where it's
highly highly adaptive so what I do see
is that globalization by the old
definition was ending for a lot of
different reasons and one of them was
that China wasn't supplying cheap stuff
anymore the quality was falling and
their wages were going up so
dramatically that the cost base was too
high so it became more efficient I mean
I make physical things I make autonomous
vehicles and drones and I can do that
less expensively with higher quality in
London than I can in China dad has been
food for more than 6 or 7 years now so
there's been a radical shift in where is
the cheap place to make things second
the labor content of most things is very
very tiny and getting smaller all the
time it has more to do with your design
has to do with coding has to do with a
lot of things that aren't the person
that you're employing and also you can
have people working remotely on a lot of
things especially if they're working on
the coding side the other thing is that
people were becoming much more cognizant
of green issues and the planet and they
didn't want to travel so much and I
don't think they're gonna want to travel
and in this new environment because of
the carbon footprint because of the cost
I mean I am one of the road warriors
right I am one of the people who
literally was doing five countries a
week when that was still possible I mean
and frankly when you talk about how bad
can this virus be you know I'm like the
model for what could be the typhoid mary
of the situation because
I'm capable of being in five countries
in a week and I don't know whether I've
had it I think that I may have had it
but until we're all tested nobody knows
and so this is why this can travel much
faster in a modern world economy than it
did in 1918 when it was only soldiers
that were on the move now it's the whole
cadre of low beliefs does like myself so
what sort of risk do we present for the
world and then there's the personal
health risk because everybody who's over
30 who tries to travel like that finds
that they end up having health issues
from doing it so in that sense I think
globalization is not dead but it is
radically transformed into entirely new
definition and a more positive
productive definition but the the other
thing I can take a second to talk about
that debt Jubilee idea because I think
this is what everybody is gonna be
talking about and the people are gonna
start say yeah I I would like to be the
beneficiary of that and I put up on
Twitter the other day that when the
sumerians first did this it was
literally I'm looking at the number now
is the year 42 72 BC I mean this is an
ancient way of handling things and the
point is if it reaches the point that
the person you've lent the money to is
dead you're not getting the money back
if they have no money in their bank
account and they're nearly dead you're
not getting your money back so what's
your priority is it to get paid back or
is it to save the society and what will
happen is we're gonna shift our
orientation from the I got to get paid
back - I need humanity to live and not
to fall into conflict hey I've got 20
years left on my mortgage I I'm sold
I'm sold I've got 20 years left on my
mortgage people before Francis jumps in
let me ask you this because you're a
former adviser to two US presidents if
you're sitting in the Oval Office right
now and you're looking at the fact and
this I'd come back to the issue of
globalization here you're looking at the
fact that 97% of your antibiotics are
made in China you know a huge quantity
and percentage of your essential
supplies are made in China a lot of
particularly right-leaning commentators
have been banging away at this point you
know we've become reliant on China for
essential supplies in a world where you
know I mean we don't know exactly what's
happened with this virus but there's
some evidence to suggest that you know
it's not without China's at best
incompetence that this has spread the
way that it has right so if you can't
trust them and you know when when the
the proverbial hits the fan countries
tend to lock down and go I need this and
you're not having that yeah are we I
know as a president of the United States
or the Prime Minister of Britain is
gonna go we need to ensure not just
manufacturing of widgets and iPhones we
need to onshore manufacture a medical
supply syringes eventer everything yes
and it's not only because you know China
didn't handle it well I think probably
most countries wouldn't have handled it
well I'm not sure that the British did
so much better and they were loaded with
a lot more information and they were
still slow but the point is the people
sorry the British didn't lie to the rest
of the world about the extent of the
deaths the infections you know it's a
try hear you I hear you and we can talk
about that you know the first point is
that China doesn't even know how to
produce accurate data because they
basically you know you I remember a
policymaker in China said to me would
you like to know next year's GDP because
I have it here in the drawer data it's
like a Western magic art that they don't
really get they just you know it's a
political process so the fact that we
haven't trusted their numbers is kind of
our problem but we're leaving that aside
the main thing is what you're talking
about is a trade-off between efficiency
and resilience and for many years we
have gone after efficiency and cheaper
prices ever cheaper prices that that was
our driver now we're faced with this
reality that resilience is is interfered
with by that and I'll come I'd like to
use the example in Formula One racing
the it's a constant race between
resilience and efficiency and what
you're doing is you rip that car apart
every single day and you try to shave
one gram of weight off of the thing so
the
to improve its chances of winning but
that one gram may be the thing that
breaks the peace you're working on so
it's either correct or catastrophe right
you're on the borderline all the time
well this is where we are with the
economy we chose efficiency efficiency
efficiency and we shaved off that extra
gram of cost by outsourcing it to China
and now we see a break and therefore now
we're gonna have an emphasis on
Brazilians now what does that mean that
means inflation that means higher prices
it means you say I'm willing to pay more
for a British sourced product or an
American sourced product so that I'm
sure to get it then I care about its
reduced cost and that's another channel
through which higher prices begin to
worm their way forward now this in the
light of the current president let's
just keep in mind who the current
president is current president itíd
States is a property guy property guys
make all their money on inflation they
love inflation and so what is his
inclination going to be is always going
to be we should just have more debt and
the way you deal with the debt is you
basically inflate and that's okay
and by the way inflation they do tend to
make asset markets go up which means
stock markets and I would argue we've
had that inflation has shown up in
recent years as higher asset prices and
everybody loved that part about it and
they ignored the fact that a consumer
had to go from 1% inflation at the time
of the financial crisis to say two and a
half at the time of the Kovach crisis
and that just sounds like nothing but to
Jim's point that's a ton of inflation
that lets you completely erode the debt
you owe the world and the u.s. is
particularly privileged in that because
everybody's still willing to buy dollars
from the states even though we behave
this way and by the way we have behaved
this way throughout history because how
did we pay for the american revolution
on inflation how did we pay for the
civil war much bigger inflation how do
we pay for Vietnam
another inflation and how are we gonna
pay for this mess on inflation and so
that's why I said at the opening I think
that we're heading into inflation so
then the question becomes what's the
speed and magnitude of that thing and I
agree with Jim usually great inflation's
are preceded by a puff of deflation and
whether that lasts a year 18 months two
years I don't know but we have seen them
they set the stage for prices to begin
creeping up and for people to say again
it's a psychological phenomena to say
you know like in my world I have people
companies are saying you know the
Chinese drones may be cheaper but I'd
rather buy British or the Chinese drones
you know maybe I can buy them the supply
chains there but I'd rather work with
someone who's closer and speaks English
and can work with me to produce what I
really require for my business that
means they're telling me they're willing
to pay more for this and I think they'll
pay more for these things now that they
go I need to be digital and I need to
not travel I need to be more localized
not globalized so in this sense it all
comes together to form a full circle
that what Jim and I have written about
inflation which everybody says is a dead
duck and never coming back to life is
distinctly quacking in the background
fantastic and I think we've come to the
end of the interview well before we do
if you guys have another five minutes
Jim I want I know you're you I think
it's fair to describe you as a china
Hawk if that's a if that's a reasonable
description what do you think will be
the implication on the us-china
relationship and actually dude that the
kind of the way that the rest of the
world uh perhaps the Western world
relates to China going forward yeah I
don't think on a hottub spectrum I think
on a realist idealist or ideologue
spectrum with the ideologues in the
aisle is getting it wrong so so China
there's very good there's visual video
anecdotal evidence that while the virus
was raging in Wuhan they put live people
in body bags and cremated them in other
words that the bags were still wiggling
and screams emerged when they went into
the crematorium
because they expected the people to die
and they said why waste baits and
resources they're going to die so just
throw them in the furnace which they did
and they didn't care they also have
large concentration camps in western
China that are where they round up
people on a religious basis or based on
the dissidents they tried to brainwash
them but in cases of failure they
strapped into a table and do organ
removal without anesthetic to supply an
organ transplant industry and then of
course those people died and they're
sent to the crematorium also something
about concentration camps and crematoria
that should give people pause in terms
of doing business with China and when
PIPA said that Chinese quality is
falling I disagree because it was
already rock bottom you can't fall from
a zero base Chinese Chinese make garbage
and they lie about it and why our
globalists ever believed them other than
the fact that they don't like America is
very hard for me to describe so the
point is if you go back to October
obviously 2019 yeah Mike Pence's speech
to the Hudson Institute and basically we
declared a new cold war on China called
cold war - that's where we are
Pippa's certainly right about Kenyan
bracelets and fish mongers but let's
talk about the pharmaceutical industry
Turkey is not going to have a thriving
pharmaceutical industry Kenya is not
gonna have a thriving pharmaceutical
industry Pharmaceuticals being the u.s.
Switzerland Canada China can just China
will hit a dead end because their
inability to steal more intellectual
property will grind this to a halt and
no one's gonna want their stuff anyway I
mean the UK just took a huge delivery of
testing kits from China and the National
National Health Service and the
laboratories rejected them within days
because they said they don't work you
know welcome to the world of Chinese
imports so a ruthless atheistic
murderous lying society has lost its
place in whatever's left of
globalization you can have trade it
doesn't mean that there won't be any
trade of course there will whether
people won't go back and forth of course
they will but with this globalization as
a byword for extended supply chains that
basically
the united states and other wealthy
countries of their wealth for the
benefit of China that's over and just to
kind of anticipate one question
constantine you said what what's coming
or what's next that no one's thinking
about we that's always our last question
so let's it I'm not my show you already
started so you might as well finish Jim
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about and we'll get to paper
after you all right well she should have
the last word um so we've talked about
the pandemic we've talked about the
economic impact we've talked about an
economic way out which is inflation
Jubilee works but I don't expect it to
happen inflation works but it's not
happening except as I described I'll
have to devalue the dollar and since you
can't devalue it against other
currencies because they wanted to buy
you also gold is your only numeraire
gold is your only form of money that's
not a national currency and therefore it
kind of stands there and takes it so you
know look for gold at you know ten
thousand dollars an ounce sooner than
later which is has nothing to do with
gold has to do with a 90 percent
devaluation of the dollar but what is
people what people are not talking about
that is coming it's just to lean forward
a little bit is social disruption that
the breakdown of society people forget
that the veneer of civilization is
paper-thin and it's torn very easily and
we're starting to see it fray because of
PIPA the very beginnings made a very
profound point she said averages don't
mean anything because they disguised the
degree distribution she's absolutely
right the averages will be horrendous
but the reality for many people will be
even worse so I would look for but you
know we already saw it with the riots
and France and she'll lose a and Hong
Kong and Santiago Chile and Beirut these
were breaking out anyway and that's
going to get worse
and over to paper what is the one thing
that we're not talking about that we
really should be very happy it's on a
lighter note but you know and the thing
is I actually do see the economy that
we're going to have I do see I'm because
I'm talking to tech firms I'm talking to
investors the world's biggest investors
everybody is still having meetings
they're making investments they're
picking things that they think will work
well in the new world that we've
described they're anticipating debt
defaults and figuring out how do I make
money out of that so I am fundamentally
optimistic we are going to have an
economy tomorrow it is being defined
today and people will be able to
participate in it but they're gonna have
to change and people don't like change
but this is going to force a lot of
people to change what they do and how
they do it and there's a lag so I agree
we're gonna have a very tough period
especially for people who who kind of
fall through and don't have support and
don't have the backing of a good network
and education and all sorts of things so
I think we have a big social issue ahead
of us but the thing that worries me that
we're not talking about is something
that happened in the run-up to World War
two which is if you create enough
dislocation and and I'm not just talking
economic dislocation I'm talking about
the fact that you know the United
Nations considers it torture when you're
put into solitary confinement for 72
hours and now we have a whole society of
people many who are alone
single elderly even the young who are
suddenly forced to spend a lot of time
alone and they're afraid and they're
worried and so one of the things that
happened in the pre-world War two period
was people just said you know what I
just want somebody who will establish
order I just want somebody who's in
charge I can't solve these huge problems
and there's a great book by Erich Fromm
about this called escape for
freedom and he basically describes the
circumstances under which a very
authoritarian leadership was able to sow
its seeds and you ended up with Hitler
now in the current environment you've
all Hariri has who wrote sapiens and
Homo Jews he just wrote a really
brilliant editorial in the Financial
Times about this where he talked about
the use of digital methods to track
citizens like you know Google gives the
information to government so you can see
where everybody's been and then you can
track the virus great but what kind of
odeur does that open to a more state
driven authoritarian society and I think
that this question about surveillance
capitalism that's the word that we use
to describe that should be thought about
now because we could very easily slip
into a more authoritarian digit digital
command economy that would diminish the
kinds of personal freedoms that we've
fought for many generations to have and
which we don't need to lose just because
we're having a moment of economic crisis
and you say no one is talking about
actually the last time you were on the
show you spent an hour talking to us
about it so someone is talking about it
thankfully I will continue to do that
but thank you both so much for your time
it's been an absolute pleasure I just
want to finish by saying that it's an
interesting time when you talk about
winners and losers because I think most
people particularly in the West have
never really lived through this
particular people my age but for me
growing up in early 1990s Russia the
concept of the world was one way and
then overnight it was another way
actually it's quite familiar you pull
you're both nodding people won't be able
to see that but you're both nodding and
so there will be winners and losers and
the people who who did well in that time
were people who adapted to people who
were willing to to learn and to change
their behavior in the new environment so
it's well it's been a depressing
conversation but I think there's also
interesting times ahead
but thank you very much both of you for
coming back on the show it's been an
absolute pleasure
if
you enjoyed this conversation make sure
you go and follow both paper and Jim on
Twitter we'll put all the links in they
both have brilliant books out which
they've talked about a whole number of
books and go back and watch the previous
interviews that we do both of them
absolutely and so thank you very much
for coming on and we will see you in a
few days guys with another fantastic
episode see you then thanks for watching
guys as always subscribe to the YouTube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pod and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word